Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
During the recent episode of Ahsoka,
there was a literal in metaphorical
Big Jedi
fallen order Jedi survivor Easter Egg.
For everything
that's going on with Cal Kestis and Merrin,
some of you may have spotted it.
It was literally standing right
in front of our faces
on the wall of the Nightsisters
Ancient Tower.
And it might contain the secret power that
Baylan Skoll says that he keeps feeling.
Called him on the Nightsisters
Planet Peridia in that other galaxy.
I know
everybody's wondering when Cal Kestis
in Merrin will show up in live action.
Those games are already canon
to the larger Star Wars universe
in the Ahsoka series
So I'll explain what the plan is for doing
those characters in live action.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
there's going to be a bunch of big stuff
coming up.
We'll cover more Easter eggs
for this and a circus Season two,
as well as The Mandalorian Season 4,
probably in the Thrawn movie.
Everything that's going on
with the Nightsisters right now,
because we're becoming
a big part of this equation.
we're also doing a Star Wars
giveaway for copies of the Mandalorian
Blu ray because of release.
And that really assumes
all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and just post
all your theories about the Nightsisters
Cal Kestis in Merrin coming to live action.
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on Ahsoka so far.
But during episode six,
when Thrawn is talking to Baylan Skoll
and Shin Hati about going to find
Sabine and Ezra, they're all standing
outside the Nightsisters large temple
at the base on the wall behind them.
There's a bunch of runes and symbols
written on it.
zoom, enhance
the language that the written in
is Ur-Kittat,
which is an old Sith language.
it's basically the Sith alphabet.
It was only spoken by members
of the Sith Empire closer to present day
people like Emperor Palpatine,
Darth Vader, even Darth Maul,
when he was a Sith,
would have all learned how to speak it
during their studies of the dark side
in the Sith.
Basically it's a secret Sith language
that only members of their order
learn to speak.
part of the reason for that, though,
is that after the great Sith War,
the old Republic banned its use.
They basically made it illegal
to speak or to write
in that old UGK attack language,
they tried to stamp out all traces of it,
but obviously some survived, like
in the unknown regions
of the Exegol planet.
And now it's showing up
in this other galaxy.
In the old Republic, it seems like
never actually went to the other galaxy.
Only the Nightsisters that live
there came to the main galaxy.
they introduced this old Sith language
during the rise of Skywalker movie.
So it's already been canon
to the Star Wars universe.
It appeared on the Exegol Sith Planet is
written all over the temple walls.
during that they also canonized Darth
Raven from the Knights of the Old Republic
Games.
He's depicted on the walls of the temple
and the writings mentioned him as well.
so now in present day,
Dave Filoni is saying
that there was a connection
between the ancient Sith Empire
in the Knight Sisters, like this
ancient witch Kingdom of the Dathmiri
and that's how their writing wound up
on the Nightsisters Temple during
the height of that ancient witch kingdom
they also said that those ancient knight
sisters also predate to the old republic.
So this goes way, way back
to the very beginning of time, basically
in the Star Wars
universe or recorded time,
that also means that it predates
the original Jedi Order as well to
recently a fan translated
the runes from ERC
attacked this ancient Sith language
and they raise praise coo jett
ruler of all
May his reign last for all time.
This is where we get to the
connections to Jedi Fallen order
Jedi survivor Merrin in Cal Kesey's
his character
during Jedi Fallen Order caucuses,
goes to a tomb of Kujet on Dathomir,
the home of the Knights
sisters in the main galaxy
and where Merrin has been living
since Order 66.
when he arrives.
This is meant to be the first time
that he actually meets her.
So she treats him kind of like an enemy.
these events were also taking place
around the same time Obi-Wan
Kenobi episodes took place about ten years
after Revenge of the Sith.
while he's there,
Caucusus runs into Terrence Malick's
a former Jedi master
who's turned to the dark side
since Order 66 and began
studying the teachings of Q Jett,
the other Zeppo in the Nightsisters.
so the whole idea is that this could yet
figure that's mentioned on the Knights
Sisters Temple Wall in the other galaxy
was part of the Zeppo
race, who they feature during the Jedi
Fallen Order Jedi Survivor games.
during the height of the Zeppo Empire,
long before the days of the old Republic.
He was a powerful, dark side.
Sage is part of their race
who created a temple on Dathomir.
The Cal Cassius is exploring here
that Merrin has been protecting
just reference, the Old Republic
era started around 25,000 years ago.
The original Jedi Order goes back about
as far as 30,000 years ago.
So this all predates that stuff, Dave
Filoni is making it sound like
either Kujet lived.
But before that era, like he lived
before the old Republic or
the ancient Nightsisters just carved
this into the temple after his death
and they continue to serve his force ghost
or as force essence.
so when we talk about force ghosts
and what happens after you die in the Star
Wars universe the rules are a little bit
different for Sith than they are for Jedi.
since can't become force ghost,
but they can bind their essence
or part of their essence
to objects like Sith holograms.
So this might be the power
the balance caulfield's
coined to him on parity
like the remnants of two jets
force spirit.
This remained alive these many, many tens
of thousands of years and in present day,
the Nightsisters might just continue
to worship him as a God
But because of the way the Nightsisters
force powers work.
As Thrawn said, death,
resurrection are just deceptions
because they can resurrect beings.
Also, you can survive after your death.
Like I said, Sith can bind their essence
to objects.
Knights
sisters can also literally resurrect
beings from death
and they have this special connection
to the force that enables them
to speak across time and space.
Also communicating
with people who have died,
that was what they were talking about
when they were referencing,
seeing the threads of destiny
and telling Thrawn about the weave.
They look at patterns in the force
across the universe in across time
that might also be the way that they can
continue to communicate with Q Jet
they can either speak
with his spirit in death
or they can hear his commands
from the distant past.
that because the Temple wall reads
that he should reign for all time,
it just screams
the concept of night sister zombies
and just surviving after death.
Which gets back to the whole Emperor
Palpatine meme have ever told you
about the tragedy of Darth Plagueis
the wise.
there are a lot of races
that are very long lived in the Star Wars
universe, like, for instance,
a ahsoka's race live for up to 200 years.
Yoda's race, people like Grogu
who live for up to 900 years.
The only actual immortal beings that
we know right now are the mortis gods.
so. When you talk about living for
all time, there are only a couple of ways
to accomplish that, aside
from just being very long lived,
is that either become a force ghost
in your essence, just survives your sins
and you trap your essence or you bind it
to an object like a Sith holic run
or you get raised from the dead
as a nice sister zombie.
the other thing too, is that Sith,
when they bind their essence to objects
like Sith holograms, they can also take
over someone else's body to.
So that would be another way for
this could jet character to come back.
that's also part of the way that Palpatine
was able to come back from the dead,
like he transferred his essence
into a new clone body.
during the Mandalorian episodes,
the Shadow
Council called that project Necromancer,
quote unquote.
so maybe Balan Skull is hearing
the call of Kujett's power.
And he's going to use that power,
try to use it to make some huge change
across time and space.
The entire universe.
And that's his way of stopping
the conflict in the cycle of order 66 is,
as he called it, the cycle of destruction,
with empires rising rebellions forming,
then happening over and over again,
just as it's happening again
with Thrones return in the Roman Empire,
seeking their revenge
like it's another version of revenge,
this is happening again.
Revenge of the Shadow Council.
Either way, it's a huge deal
that Dave Filoni is making this connection
between the ancient Sith, the Zippo
from the Jedi, Fallen Order Jedi Survivor
games in the Nightsisters
Ancient Empire of the Dathmiri,
based on the Star Wars timeline, too.
If Q Jet was his Zeppo and predicted
almost everything we know
about the old Republic Air
of the Ancient Empire, it also sounds like
they're implying that the ancient
Sith culture, not the race itself,
but the Sith Order, is entirely based
on the teachings of this coup
jet Zeppo like, he's the true
father of the Sith Order in a way.
In everyone up to Emperor Palpatine
had been studying Dark Side and Sith
Lord derived from his teachings
for many, many tens of thousands of years.
Now, this doesn't explain the connection
between the ancient Nine Sisters and
the ancient Sith who created their temples
on that Exegol Sith planet.
It sounds like those Sith
might have been part of the ancient witch
kingdom of the Death theory
at one point, or some offshoot.
the Ahsoka episodes that implied
that the story of the main galaxy,
like everything began in the other galaxy
with those Nightsisters in the
ancient witch kingdom, and at some point
they colonized the main galaxy.
And I think the reason they did that
initially before these old Republic days,
like before the rise of the ancient Jedi
Order, was because they were searching
for more sources
of their green magic force energy
that only exists on Dathomir
in the main galaxy.
That's meant to be the source
of all their power.
So it's probably why
they settled on Dathomir
and why this Zeppo could yet
also built his temple.
There.
some of you may realize this, though,
but the nine Sisters rays are humanoid
like they look pretty human Goo
Jett was a Zippo in his rays, obviously,
biologically very, very different
during the Jedi fallen order, Jedi
survivor James Calkins just learns
that they're meant to be an ancient race
that predated all known
modern species in the main galaxy.
turning the timeline, though?
What happened to this quiet jet? Zippo.
The rest of the Zippo race is meant to be
similar to what happened to the infinite
Ricotta Empire in
how the Witch Kingdom of the Dathmiri.
The Zeppo were very powerful in the force.
Naturally, like Yoda's race,
like Grogu, who their race hit its peak
like these other empires.
Then ultimately,
they were corrupted
by the dark side of the force,
eventually causing civil wars
until a small group of the Zephyr
decided to colonize the unknown regions
and live in peace.
ultimately in the main galaxy,
the dark side Zephyr just died out.
But their teachings, it sounds like,
lived on and survived into the ancient
Sith Empire in the Witch
Kingdom of the Dathmiri
who worshiped them
kind of like their gods.
the Ahsoka episodes.
And now these ruins make
it sound like puja dates
back to the height of that witch
kingdom of the dathmiri
Really cool to see Dave Filoni
doing more Cal Kestis Merrin
connections in live action.
They definitely have a plan
for doing those characters in live action.
Eventually.
and within the Cal Kesey's
trilogy of games.
There is enough going on there, enough
backstory, enough room in the story
that they can just give Cal cast
as his own live action series.
like. Yes.
Eventually
cross them over with the mando verse
in that part of the timeline, eventually
when he's a little bit older,
but also just give him his own series
earlier in the timeline
just because Cameron
Monahan is still so young in real life,
they can do multiple seasons of a Cal cast
in series set before the events of and
or or if they wait a little bit longer
they can also do it later
after Return of the Jedi
as part of the Mandalorian spin offs
in a different part of the Galaxy.
eventually, Luke Skywalker
would learn about him when he began
actively seeking out for sensitives
to train at his new Jedi Academy.
Grogu, who just happened to be
the first one that he found
entering that part of the timeline, it's
implied during Jedi Survivor that caucus's
ultimate plan with Merrin was to continue
his relationship with her and help
other Jedi Force senses find a place
where they could live out their lives
they imply
that place is the ten Lord planet
just because of how well defended it is.
The natural phenomena of the nebula
destroying most ships that try to enter it
or find a path through.
It's the safest place in the galaxy
for them to all
stay hidden from Darth Vader
and the inquisitors.
Aside from just being lost
in the unknown region somewhere, are also
a lot of other threats
in the unknown regions.
Those are teasing that out
through Grandad, both from story
the chase as well as the risk.
There's lots of stuff going on in
the unknown regions just in general
is this very new fertile story territory
that Star Wars hasn't explored yet.
so after the fall of the Empire,
it just sounds like Cal Kesey's plans
to train New Jedi there on Tanner
lore using the Jedi books to survive.
They only have three books it's
kind of like Luke Skywalker also trying
to create a new Jedi Order using
limited materials that survived Order 66.
but the whole idea
is that all these different figures
like Grogu, Luke Skywalker, Cal Cousins,
all have very different ideas about
how to pursue their training in the force.
like Grogu
won't turn out exactly like Yoda.
He'll be more like
TAA Vizsla, the first Mandalorian Jedi,
because he both became Amanda Laurean.
But he'll also continue
training in the force.
same thing with Cal Kestis, who also has
Merrin, a Knights sister who uses the force
in a very different way,
who will be helping train New Jedi.
His order would look completely different
than Luke Skywalker's Jedi Order.
So there is a grand plan for the caucuses
character in live action
series and movies.
If everything works out long term and we
are talking about long term, in addition
to crossing over with the other new movies
and series,
he would just get his own series Burma
and that's still years and years away.
We still have the next game in the trilogy
in about four years.
let me know in the comments,
Where's the first place
you want to see Cal Cassius appear
in the live action series and movies?
would you rather see him
during future seasons of Ahsoka?
The Main Mandalorian series might be done
after the next 4 to 5 years,
but Ahsoka will go a little past that in
according to Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni,
there will be other spinoffs
in that part of the timeline after Ahsoka
and The Mandalorian in their run
or would you rather see a live action?
Calkins The series
and have other characters like Ahsoka
and Luke Skywalker cameo during that?
Dave Filoni has just started teasing
that true history of what's going on
with the Nightsisters
in this other galaxy,
this ancient witch kingdom of the Dathmiri.
So we'll learn a little bit more
in the last couple of episodes of Ahsoka
but a lot of that will carry forward
into the Thrawn movie,
The Mandalorian Season
4, Ahsoka Season 2.
Don't worry, I'll do videos
for all that stuff.
Click here for my Ahsoka
Episode seven video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!